LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
Today I'm meeting
with Michelle Haq,
who's a product manager on
the Google Fit platform.
Now, the Google Fit
platform is capable of doing
so many things, and
Michelle is going to tell us
all about them today.
Michelle, thanks so much for
coming having coffee with me.
Everybody wants
to know about Fit.
Everybody wants to
learn more about Fit.
What exactly is Fit?
What exactly is
the Fit platform?
What does it do?
MICHELLE HAQ: The main
goal of the Fit platform
is to have a place for the
entire user's fitness history
consolidated.
So this means that if
I have one app that I
use to log my
calories, a heart rate
monitor that I'm using
when I'm running,
and a third app where I log
my cycles or my bike rides,
then all of the data can
be in Fit and these apps
can interact in
a meaningful way.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
MICHELLE HAQ: And then the
other cool thing that Fit does
is that it basically creates
a computation layer where
we detect your active time,
your steps, your distance,
your speed, et cetera, and we
basically turn the 1 billion
Google Play Service Android
devices into free fitness
trackers, and then we allow
developers to access the data
from those computations.
And then you've
probably also noticed
that we have a Google Fit app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Of course.
MICHELLE HAQ: So
the app, I think,
really illustrates
very well the power
of the platform
because in it, you
can see the user's
full fitness history.
You can see your weight
from any smart scales that
are connected to
Fit, you can see runs
from any of our
running partners,
like for example,
RunKeeper, Strava,
and then you also see
our all day activity.
That showcases the
fitness tracker
computations that we have.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I
love how it reminds me, hey,
you've met your
goal for the day,
and every day when it
gets earlier and earlier,
it feels really good.
Not meeting you goal
for the day at midnight,
yet meeting your goal for the
day at 4:00 PM feels good.
MICHELLE HAQ: That's great.
We're happy about that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
that's a great user story
there about it, but
what about developers?
What's the developer
story for Fit?
MICHELLE HAQ: So as
a developer, there's
a few things you
can use Fit for.
One of the cool
use cases is taking
advantage of the computations.
So if I want to build,
say, a running app,
then I don't have to do
that from scratch anymore.
I can subscribe to all of the
data that Fit is computing.
Another cool thing
I can do is use Fit
as a proxy to get access
to the user's fitness data.
So I can get access to the data
from the user of other apps
that connect to Fit,
the hardware that
connects to Fit, et cetera.
And then one cool
thing you can do
as an app maker or
even a hardware maker
is use Fit as your
API for getting data
to other developers in
lieu of building an API.
And even if you
already have an API,
Fit is a good proxy for the
fragmented fitness ecosystem
that we have, and so
it's still a good idea
to integrate with
Fit in order to get
more access to the people who
might want to read your data.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
There's one thing
there that sometimes
makes the spidey senses tingle
when you hear about people
reading your data,
that there might
be like some privacy
implications or anything
like that.
MICHELLE HAQ: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: What
you do to address that?
MICHELLE HAQ: This is
really important to us,
making sure that the user
knows who's reading their data.
So as a developer, if I
want to read a user's data
or write to it, then
the user has to give me
explicit permission to do.
So the user will get a pop
up, and it's going to say,
this developer wants to
read this data from you.
The user has to say yes.
And then at any time,
the user can also
go into the Google Settings app
and revoke access to their fit
history from any app.
So at the end of
the day, the power
to distribute your
fitness history
is in the hands of the user.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So I can imagine
when building a platform
like this, testing
is something that's a little
different with a fitness
platform.
It's not like an app
where you can just
get automatic testing of it.
You've got to go out
and actually do stuff.
How did that work out?
Did you have any fun with it?
MICHELLE HAQ: Yeah.
Well, I can say
the entire team is
a lot fitter because
of the testing
because you do have to go out.
You have to run.
You have to cycle.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I think
I need to join your team.
MICHELLE HAQ: Yeah.
This is the only team I've
been on where going for a run
during lunch is adding value to
your project, which is really
fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
Nice.
MICHELLE HAQ: There was
a guy on our QA team
who used to tell me, I
don't run, I'm not a runner,
but he wanted to test out
Fit so he started running,
and recently he did his first
four mile run, which I think
is a pretty long distance.
It was kind of nice
to see him up his game
because he wanted to use
our product and test it out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's
impacting his life as well as
his career.
MICHELLE HAQ: Yeah, I hope so.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
Michelle, one of the things
is when you're building
a platform like this,
there's always somebody who
comes up with something really
innovative that just comes
out of the blue and totally
surprises you.
Were there any with Google Fit?
MICHELLE HAQ: Yeah.
There have been a few, actually,
but one that comes to mind
is a Wear app, and
it's using Fit,
and it's called
Max My Fitness Dog.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
MICHELLE HAQ: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I love it.
MICHELLE HAQ: It's a virtual
pet, and it's this dog,
and to take care of him,
you have to stay active.
So it's kind of a cool,
gamified fitness thing,
and it's also on Wear.
I love that they
were this creative.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That
sounds really fun.
I've got to give that a try, but
my real dog might get jealous.
MICHELLE HAQ: He might.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So just
come back to developers again
for a moment.
We've seen like there's
lots of great scenarios
you've mentioned,
and maybe somebody
wants to build the next
virtual pet or something
along those lines, but how
does a developer get started?
MICHELLE HAQ: So you
can get started by going
to developers.google.com/fit,
and all of our documentation is
there.
We also have a pretty
burgeoning G+ community,
and the developers in that
community are amazing.
They're very competent.
They even respond to
technical questions
and report bugs and
make suggestions.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
The best community.
MICHELLE HAQ: It's
the best community.
I encourage everybody to go join
that community once they get
started.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So developers.google.com/fit?
MICHELLE HAQ: Correct.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
First of all, thanks Michelle
Haq for coming and joining us,
and you heard it here,
developers.google.com/fit
if you want to get started
building fitness apps,
or if you want to start
integrating data from sensors
that maybe you don't control,
or if you want to build the next
great virtual pet
or another great,
innovative scenario
like that one.
Thanks so much for
joining us, Michelle.
It's been a real blast.
MICHELLE HAQ: Thanks
for having me.